[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen guten Abend wünsche ich
Ihnen was spannendes im Sport passiert
ist das erfahren Sie von Sven Foss auch
von mir einen schönen guten Abend unsere
Themen heute Krieg im gazaastreifen
während an der Grenze zu Ägypten
tausende Menschen auf die Ausreise
hoffen rückt Israels immer weiter vor
Orkantief kieren wütet über Westeuropa
mehr als eine Million Haushalte sind in
Frankreich zeitweise ohne Strom in
Deutschland stirbt eine Frau und
sbrücken schafft die Sensation der
Drittligist wirft Rekordmeister Bayern
München aus dem DFB Pokal und zieht ins
Achtelfinale die Stimmen werden lauter
die auf eine Feuerpause im Krieg
zwischen Israel und der Hamas drängen us
Präsident Biden hat für eine Pause
pläert damit es Zeit gebe die Geiseln
herauszuholen zudem forderte un
Generalsekretär guterrisch erneut mehr
Hilfe für die Menschen in Gaza die
israelischen Truppen sollen mittlerweile
über die Außenbezirke von gazastadt
hinausgekommen sein mehr von Tim
Kröger wieder Bilder heftiger Zerstörung
offenbar die Folge von Luftangriffen
dieses Mal hat es die Mitte des Gaza
Streifens in B und auch in magasi
getroffen
dieses Haus wurde zerbombt mit Anwohnern
Zivilisten Kindern und älteren es gab
keine
Warnung im flüchtlingsviertel jabalia im
Norden Gazas kommen die Menschen
ebenfalls nicht zur Ruhe auch heute soll
es Angriffe gegeben haben Helfer
versuchen verzweifelt einen Überlebenden
aus dem Schut zu
bergen am Boden gehen die Kämpfe
zwischen der Hamas und israelischen
Truppen weiter es habe stundenlange
nächtliche Gefechte von Angesicht zu
Angesicht gegeben so das israelische
Militär wir sind schon über die Vororte
von gazastadt hinaus vorgedrungen es
geht voran leider haben wir auch
Verluste schmerzliche Verluste bei den
Angehörigen gefallener israelischer
Soldaten sind Leid und Trauer groß
bislang sind während der Bodenoffensive
im Gazastreifen 19 Soldaten ums Leben
gekommen Leon siminov wurde 19 Jahre
[Musik]
alt st immer unser ganzer Stolz sein ich
liebe dich so sehr ich vermisse dich so
sehr ich kann es nicht
glauben angespannt ist die Lage auch im
Norden Israels aus dem Libanon wurden
Raketen abgeschossen die Stadt kirmona
wurde getroffen Israel griff nach
eigenen Angaben Stellungen der
schiitischen hisbolliz
an und wir schauen noch mal in den
gazreifen dort versuchen sich viele vor
den Kämpfen in Sicherheit bring etwa 400
Menschen mit ausländischenem Pass
konnten heute über den Grenzübergang
Rafa nach Ägypten ausreisen rund 7000
warten weiter darauf unter ihnen auch
eine niedrige dreistellige Zahl
deutscher golinei
berichtet hunderte Schicksale in einem
Raum wer es hierhin geschafft hat auf
einer Liste seiner Botschaft landete und
einen Stempel im Pass ergatterte hat
gute Aussichten weiterzukommen mehr als
380 doppelstatler sollen bis zum Abend
Ägypten erreicht haben und 21
Schwerverletzte viele blicken mit
Entsetzen
zurück ich habe Angst um meine Freunde
die Mutter meiner Freunde starb als sie
hausbombardiert
wurde wir sind von einem Ort zum
nächsten gezogen weil unser Haus
bombardiert wurde ich bin Zivilistin was
habe ich bitte mit der Hamas zu
tun unter den Ausreisenden Amerikaner
Tschechen Mexikaner Kroaten oder Belgier
deutsche stehen heute nicht auf der
Liste vielleicht gehbe es morgen eine
Chance für Sie heißt es hier vielleicht
aber auch erst am Samstag er ist einer
von ihnen der Berliner Abed Hassan er
besuchte seine Familie als der Krieg
begann jetzt kann er den Norden gasas
nicht mehr verlassen und hat sich ans
auswertiger Amt gewandt hier
noch ich habe bisher selbst
keine Information bekommen das einzige
ist was ich was mir gesagt wurde es gibt
keine Lösung und ich muss mich an die
deutsche Vertretung in Rama wenden und
warten was dann entsprechend passiert
der Weg zur Grenze im Süden sei extrem
gefährlich sagt Hassan wer hierher will
muss auf eigene Gefahr
reisen wir sehen also einige wenige
dürfen Gasa verlassen LP aber es sind
mindestens Menschen im Süden Gazas was
passiert mit
denen im Prinzip bleibt denen nur die
Hoffnung zum einen die Hoffnung darauf
dass die israelischen Luftschläge sie
nicht treffen also den Süden des
Gazastreifens und dann die Hoffnung
natürlich dass mehr und schneller Hilfe
hineinkommt in den Gazastreifen da gab
es heute eine interessante Aussicht
gewissermaßen der Generalstabschef der
israelischen Armee hat heute
angekündigten man könne durchaus unter
Umständen auch treibstofflieferungen in
den Gasastreifen ermöglichen unter
schweren Kontrollen es müsste dann
direkt an die Krankenhäuser geliefert
werden nicht an die Hamas aber immerhin
das war schon mein erstes Zeichen dass
sich etwas bewegt er hat natürlich nicht
gesagt ab wann das geschehen könnte
morgen wird das auch Thema beim Besuch
des amerikanischen ausenministers
blinken hier in Israel sein die
Amerikaner fordern inzwischen auch eine
temporäre humanitäre Feuerpause wie es
heißt keine Hoffnung ist jedenfalls von
der Hamas zu erwarten da gab es heute
ein interessantes Video eines interv
eines Hamas Sprechers im libanesischen
Fernsehen der hat gesagt man werde
Israel bis zur Vernichtung weiter
bekämpfen und sei bereit jeden Preis
dafür zu zahlen man sei so wörtlich
stolz darauf palästinensische das
palästinensische Volk zu opfern als
merter wie das im Gazastreifen ankommt
wissen wir nicht wie gesagt der Mann
sitzt im sicheren Beirut l weport vielen
Dank in Deutschland geht man jetzt noch
stärker gegen die islamistische Hamas
und Ihre Unterstützung vor so hat
bundesinnenministerin Feser bekannt
gegeben dass die Terrororganisation
Hamas und das Netzwerk samidun seit
heute verboten sind was das genau für
Konsequenzen hat berichtet Christian
Volk 7 Oktober Berlin Neuköln wenige
Stunden nach den Angriffen der
Terrororganisation Hamas auf Israel
feiern dutzende die Taten aufgerufen
hatte das palästinensische Netzwerk
samidun heute verbietet die
Innenministerin die Aktivitäten von un
und
Hamas das heißt dass wir nicht zuschauen
dass auf den Straßen in Deutschland die
der widerwärtige barbarische Angriff der
Hamas auf Israel hier bejubelt wird
samidun verbreitet laut Innenministerium
antisemitische Propaganda und
unterstützt mehrere
Terrororganisationen wie etwa die Hamas
die steht bereits seit 2001 auf der EU
Terrorliste womit sie de facto schon
verboten ist die neue Regelung macht es
für die Behörden aber nun einfacher
einzuschreiten etwa bei Veranstaltungen
oder wenn Sympathisanten Spenden
sammeln diese Verbote wirken wir kennen
das aus anderen terrorismusbereichen aus
der
Rockerkriminalität wir sehen dass die
Menschen in dem Netzwerk sich natürlich
anders verhalten aber das Verbot
öffentlich wahrnehmbar wird natürlich
auch Menschen abhalten diese
Organisationen zu unterstützen die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen vor jüdischen
richtungen seit Wochen erhöht das Verbot
der terrorunterstützer dürfe nur ein
erster Schritt sein sagt der Zentralrat
auch die Mitglieder von samidun sind mit
einem Verbot der Organisation jetzt
nicht verschwunden also gilt es die
Szene weiterhin zu beobachten die
Polizei geht davon aus dass die Verbote
von Hamas und samidun die
proalästinensischen Proteste anfachen
könnten blicken wir auf die Ukraine
bundesaußenministerin berburg hat im
Land erneut eine eumgliedschaft in
Aussicht gestellt sie sei überzeugt dass
auch der Europäische Rat im Dezember
dieses Signal geben werde in der Ukraine
gehen währenddessen die Kämpfe
unvermindert weiter die russischen
Truppen greifen derzeit vor allem im
Osten des Landes an fker dutchek
berichtet russische Angriffe auf 118
ukrainische Städte und Gemeinden in nur
24 Stunden die Regierung in Kiev spricht
von dem intensivsten Beschuss seit
Jahresbeginn auch in on und Nikopol vor
allem aber im Osten des Landes kupjansk
bachmut Marinka und immer wieder
avdivka die ukrainischen Truppen sollen
hier aktuell rund 40.000 russischen
Soldaten gegenüber
stehen sie haben mehr Ressourcen mehr
Munition wenn wir so viel Munition
hätten könnten wir besser kämpfen aber
wir haben diese Option nicht also müssen
wir mit dem zurecht kommmen was wir
haben Experten sehen neue Konzentrierung
auf die Front in avdivka als taktisches
Manöver aus Moskau die
Ukraine hat bei der Gegenoffensive im
Süden einiges erreicht und jetzt möchte
Russland die Ukraine von dieser
Gegenoffensive abbringen und versucht
mit aller Macht ja schon seit einiger
Zeit bei
avdevka aber jetzt auch an anderen
Stellen der Front im Osten die Ukraine
dazu zu zwingen dass sie z.B Reserven
aus dem Süden in den Osten bringen muss
bisher hat Russland aber trotz dieser
Bemühung keine Erfolge erzielen für
viele Ukrainer ist die Verteidigung von
Städten wie avdivka bachmut und
zaporishia ein Symbol für den Widerstand
gegen die Übermacht auch am 617 Tag des
Krieges und eine ausführliche Analyse
der Situation in der Ukraine gibt es ab
19:30 Uhr bei ZDF heute live auf unseren
Social Media Kanälen und in der ZDF
heute
App die Konjunktur in Deutschland
schwächelt das wirkt sich jetzt auch
zunehmend auf den Arbeitsmarkt aus die
übliche Herbstbelebung bleibt nämlich
aus nach Angaben der Bundesagentur für
Arbeit waren im Oktober rund 2,6
Millionen Menschen ohne Job das sind nur
20 000 weniger als im Vormonat bei einer
unveränderten Quote von
5,7%. im Vergleich zum Vorjahr sind aber
165 000 Menschen mehr ohne
Arbeit
Computersysteme in Deutschland sind so
gefährdet wie noch nie das zeigt der
Lagebericht des Bundesamts für
Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik
BSI täglich würden dutzende neue
Software Schwachstellen registriert
Hacker die systematisch nach diesen
Schwachstellen suchten und sie nutzten
könnten damit erheblichen Schaden
anrichten eine zusätzliche Gefahr drohe
durch den Missbrauch von künstlicher
Intelligenz pakistan will Millionen
afghanische flüchtete in ihr Heimatland
abschieben bei Hilfsorganisation und den
Vereinten Nationen stößt das auf Kritik
insgesamt leben mehr als 4 Millionen
Afghaninnen und Afghanen in Pakistan
rund die Hälfte davon ohne Papiere und
das teilt seit Jahrzehnten zuletzt sind
viele aus Afghanistan geflohen als die
Taliban dort wieder die Macht übernommen
haben Johannes
hanno sie suchen in den Trümmer nach den
Resten ihrer Existenz afghanische
Flüchtlinge am Stadtrand von Islamabad
gestern Nachmittag waren die bulldoer
gekommen nachdem ein Ultimatum der
pakistanischen Regierung ausgelaufen war
bis 16 Uhr hatten sogenannte illegale
Flüchtlinge Zeit das Land freiwillig zu
verlassen ich habe noch nie in
Afghanistan gelebt ich kam als Säugling
und so behandelt uns die pakistanische
Regierung jetzt schau das da waren
unsere Häuser das ist unsere Situation
jetzt dass sie ist ernst mein daran
hatte die pakistanische Regierung vor
Ablauf des Ultimatums keinen Zweifel
len ich warne alle die hier illegal
leben sie sollten besser freiwillig
gehen bevor wir sie Zwangs
deportieren wir haben unsere
Hausaufgaben gemacht wir wissen wo sich
alle
aufhalten bisl aber haben nur etwa
200000 geschätzt mehr als 2 Millionen
undokumentierten Flüchtlinge das Land
verlassen der offizielle Grund warum die
pakistanische Regierung plötzlich so
unbarmherzig gegen die Flüchtlinge
vorgeht Polizei und geheimdien machen
sie für viele Selbstmordattentate und
Anschläge im Land verantwortlich aber es
gibt wohl auch noch einen anderen Grund
pakistan hat mit einer Inflation von um
die 30% zu kämpfen und das Land wandelt
am Rande des Staatsbankrotts in der
Vergangenheit hatte die pakistanische
Regierung auch immer wieder darauf
verwiesen dass die hohe Anzahl der
Flüchtlinge im Land eine enorme
finanzielle Belastung sein und im
Februar sind Wahlen in Pakistan auch das
wohl ein Grund für die kurzfristige
Massenabschiebung es ist ein gewaltiger
Orkan der auf den Nordwesten Frankreichs
und den Südwesten Englands getroffen ist
erer auch die Niederlande und
Deutschland erfasst hat Meter hohe
wellendonnern an Land hunderte Flüge
werden gestrichen insgesamt sterben
sieben Menschen in Frankreich sind
hunderttausende zeitweise ohne Strom
wedert chchigö mit
Einzelheiten mit bis zu 200 km pro
Stunde fegt der Orkan über den
Nordwesten Frankreichs hinweg der Sturm
trifft mit voller Wucht auf Küstenorte
vor allem in der britannie umgestürzte
Bäume blockieren Straßen und
Bahnstrecken der Wind reißt auch Dächer
Weg gegen 2 Uhr morgens hörte ich ein
lautes Geräusch ich konnte sehen wie das
Dach zu steigen begann und dann eine
halbe Stunde später stürzte alles ein
1,2 Millionen Haushalte sind am Morgen
ohne Strom bei 10tausenden Menschen
funktioniert das Mobilfunknetz nicht
mehr bisher melden die franzö Behörden
zwei Tote ein Lastwagenfahrer stirbt als
er in einen umgestürzten Baum kracht
auch im Süden Englands Orkanböhen so
heftig wie lange nicht mehr die größten
Zerstörungen sind auf den Inseln im
ermelkanal vor allem auf Jersey die
Polizei warnt den ganzen Tag über die
Bewohner sie sollen drin bleiben aber
manche müssen notgedrungen ihre Häuser
doch
verlassen es fühlte sich an als ob sich
das Dach hob und wieder runterackte das
war unheimlich wir waren
chroen etwas abgeschwächt trifft der
Sturm auch Deutschland im
niedersächsischen gosta stirbt eine
46-jährige Frau durch einen umstürzenden
Baum noch bis Freitagmorgen sei vor
allem in der Westhälfte mit starkem Wind
sowie Orkanböhen zu rechnen war der
Deutsche
Wetterdienst für ihre Millionen Fans
sind die Beatles längst unsterblich ihre
Songs haben Musikgeschichte geschrieben
und mehr als ein halbes Jahrhundert nach
ihrer Trennung ist heute ein kleines
Kapitel dazuekommen now and then eine
brandneue Single Original von den
fabulous F eingespielt obwohl zwei von
ihnen längst nicht mehr unter uns sind
wie dieses kleine Wunder geschehen
konnte das weiß Wolf Christian
[Musik]
rrich so klingt der letzte Song der
Beatles now eine John Lennon Ballade
unverkennbar und berührend geschrieben
in den SP
J jetzt neu aufgearbeitet das
musikalische Testament einer
[Musik]
jahrhundertband ich habe geweint als ich
den Song hörte sagt der Musikkritiker
des independent John Lenn Stimme klingt
so klar es fühlt sich an wie damals
einfachat studotechnik und kstlich
intellchen
Glas
[Musik]
heruszul mne undar haben die Instrumente
dazu neu eingespielt auch von George
Harrison gibt es noch die
Gitarrenspur spektakulär wie ein Song
aus den 70er Jahren auch ein halbes
Jahrhundert später noch bewegt mehr neue
Beatles Songs wird es so
stellt
wiergeben so s du hattest ja gestern
schon Überraschung dabei vom DFB Pokal
was sagst du jetzt zu sabrücken ja das
ist dann wahrscheinlich die
größtmögliche Überraschung Drittligist
erster FC sabrücken wirft den
Rekordpokalsieger Bayern München raus
während im Saarland anschließend eine
Riesenparty gefeiert wird herrscht bei
den Bayern
Frust für die einen ist es der
vielleicht größte Moment ihrer
Fußballerkarriere die anderen können
nicht anders reagier
fassslosigit schwer für uns zu
akzeptieren natürlich weil damit
titelfutsch ist und weil wir da mit
aller Macht nach Berlin wollten es
begint standesgemäß für die Bayern
Thomas Müller bringt sein Team nach
einer Viertelstunde in Führung doch die
Verletzung von Abwehrchef Matthis
delicht er wird wohl se Wochen fehlen
sie bringt Unordnung in den Abwehrblock
der Bayern der Drittliga 15 von der
gleicht
aus kurz vor der
Pause en die Bayern mit macht doch ein
Tor will nicht fallen auch dank der
starken sarücker torwartsteam Schreiber
mit frischen Kräften von der Bank
scheint der Münchner Sieg allerdings nur
eine Frage der Zeit ich glaub das musste
auch in der regulären Spielzeit sein
dass wir nach 9 oder bzw der
Nachspielzeit das Tor machen weil 120 h
man nicht geschafft se Minute der
Nachspielzeit das unglaubliche geschieht
Gaus trifft der Favorit ist ko der
krasse auenseiter triumphiert das
spielwi W realch Glück mus zu passen
alles passt an diesem Abend für den
Außenseiter die großen Münchner Bayern
scheitern an einem sabrüer Team das
immer an seine Chance geglaubt
hat und am Samstag dann das Spitzenspiel
für die Bayern in Dortmund unter den
letzten 16 Teams im Pokal sind übrigens
nur noch sechs Bundesliga Clubs
überraschend raus ist auch der SC
Freiburg gegen den SC Paderborn war in
der zweiten Runde Endstation Philip
bilbia sorgte mit dem 3:0 in der 56
Minute für die Vorentscheidung am Ende
gewinnt der Zweitligist in Freiburg mit
3:1 und steht im
Achtelfinale und ganz aktuell nach dem
schlechtesten oder Saisonstart der
Clubgeschichte ist Bo senson nicht
länger Trainer von mainz05 nach Saison
übergreifend 14 Bundesliga Spielen ohne
Sieg und im gestrigen Pokal aus gegen
Herter BSC trat der 44jährige heute
zurück im Alter von 94 Jahren ist die
alsis
kunstlaufstrainerin Jutta Müller
gestorben die gebürtige kemnitzerin
feierte mit Katharina Witt Olympia Gold
1984 und 88 juta Müller war berüchtigt
für ihre Strenge und wurde bewundert für
ihre großen
Erfolge das war's vom Sport danke schön
Sven wie stürmisch es heute Nacht und
morgen in Deutschland und Europa wird
erfahren Sie gleich von Katja hornifer
das heute journal können Sie um 21:45
Uhr mit Christian sie sehen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend Orkan Kiron ist
wirklich schnell über uns hinweggezogen
hier über den Ärmelkanal und in Süden
Englands weiter bis zur Nordsee dort
bewegt es sich jetzt kaum noch das sieht
mit anderen Tiefs anders aus z. mit
diesem Tief hier über ober Italien das
bringt viel Regen in den Alpen auch
schneemit und Orkanböhen z.B über dem
apenin dieses Tief hier vor Frankreich
bringt auch Orkanböhen die könnten heute
Nacht auch Bordeaux erreichen deutlich
ruhiger wird die Nacht bei uns
sturmböhen beschränken sich auf die
nordseküste im Osten fällt Regen und an
den Alpen oberhalb von 1000 m etwas
Schnee im Westen ist es dagegen zum Teil
auch mal klar dann bildet sich Nebel die
Temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 2° und
morgen bleibt es kühler als heute mit
höchstemperat turen zwischen 6 und 12°.
der Regen der Nacht zieht morgen
Vormittag bereits ostwärts ab es kann
vielleicht noch nasse Schneeflocken an
den Alpen geben dann wird's freundlich
es entwickeln sich vielleicht noch
einige Regenschauer am Nachmittag im
Nordwesten und es gibt noch stürmische
böhnen an der Nordsee am Samstag und am
Sonntag gibt's den nächsten Sturm
zunächst im Westen dann im Südwesten
deutlich freundlicher ist es im Osten
als im Westen mit mehr Sonnenschein und
wechselhaft startet dann auch die neue
Woche guten Abend